[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are talking about our
top 10 favorite
albums
i'm excited about this because well this
is what you would like to do every week
if we could
um this was a very difficult process for
me we talked about this way more
outside of this podcast than we should
have just qualifying
what went into this list
you know it's not the top 10 best albums
of all time it's not the top like best
musical musically album this is like for
me it was a combination of albums that
are meaningful and albums that i just
think are really good but i'm very like
preemptively self-conscious about it
because when i started looking at it i
was just like man i don't know how to
put these in order i've got like more
than 10 honorable mentions sure i feel
self-conscious about my number one like
there's just lots of qualifiers coming
in
so this is because
i can't it's a very difficult exercise i
just asked me what my favorite food is
of course i don't know what your list is
but you've told me what you just said
about your number one i'm shocked
that you're self-conscious about your
number one because i thought i knew what
it would be and now i'm questioning that
for me
we don't have to get into that really
yeah yeah definitely
definitely i thought i knew you
i thought i knew you're number one my
number one is don't it's good i have to
say it's gonna be you're gonna be like i
think you're gonna be like really
i think that's what you're gonna say
well okay because because i literally
said that to myself when it got done
this was an easy process for me because
it's something that i did
like
two years ago when i
maybe i don't know when i started my
record collection but
when i started collecting physical vinyl
albums
uh
the way that i did that was the albums
that
were my favorite over the course of my
life and really the criteria was
what albums like complete
artistic releases that are works from a
particular point in time i don't know if
you know what an album is but that's my
definition
uh that
meant something to me that were very
meaningful to me
i mean the the thing with both of us is
you know it
at
at our experience in our 40s how old are
you are you 44 yet
uh i'm working 43.
we
we both
experienced
albums growing up i mean we listened to
tapes then we listened to cds
you know when an artist put out a
complete work that was the main way
besides the radio of course that we
would experience
what an artist wanted to put out it
wasn't single oriented and it was
physical it wasn't streaming and
everything wasn't at our fingertips so
whatever you acquired
it it had a way of
it had a lot of potential meaning to you
because it became an active physical
repeatable part of your life in a
limited pool
depending on what your music budget was
of of of how much how many albums you
could buy and that was the only way that
you could enjoy me like you said it was
the only way you could really enjoy
music outside of the radio was you had
the tape you had the record
and
obviously we've completely transitioned
into a single
this you know music streaming has just
turned this into a just a singles
industry
um but there's a bias towards albums for
us for us that will never go away
because the majority of our life we
experienced our life
through albums and
i mean for me there were many
i you know i i
we both love music so much i know it's
you know sometimes i try to like
maybe it's we've talked about the fact
that you perceive that i kind of like i
got the corner on being a music lover
but i really acknowledge but no but this
is something that has been in your mind
your entire life when you found out that
emmy your stepsister liked music you
thought that you couldn't like music so
you've seen music as a thing that has to
be like possessed yeah by you personally
but i don't actually see it that way and
that's what i'm acknowledging that music
has been a huge part of both of our
lives in our friendship i think you'll
see from my list that like you've had an
absolute you've had a tremendous impact
on my music taste and i'm excited to
talk about that i'm also excited
to have some visual aids here i got i'm
gonna show i brought in some albums now
of course we never bought albums
we bought tapes then we bought cds but
now i'm going back and buying albums
because i don't have my tapes
well actually i do still have a lot of
my cds yeah and i and i have fully and
you know i still value the album
but i'm not a i'm not a collector it's
not in my personality to collect things
right so i've actually had to resist
because what is in my personality is to
get interested in things and to go
through phases and i've actually had to
hold myself back and make a definitive
decision that you're not going to be
that guy who gets a record player and
gets a you've got
too many things already so don't
don't do that don't get a really nice
record player and start collecting
albums so i'm never going to do it so
and now you can have that i'm so
yeah it is an active hobby of mine and
maybe that maybe that's the only
difference we can point to but some
putting together my top ten list was
really easy for me but again
the the there is some overlap in my list
between what would be my favorite albums
and what i believe or the
the best albums
that i like of all time there might be a
few that would overlap
and that that maybe that's different for
you and how you put your album uh list
together i'll say up front and there's
some there's some definitively bad music
on my on my in my title yeah i got some
of that too because it meant something
to me at the time and i will be showing
the records so if you're for for
the video viewing
uh
v well i guess that's the viewer out
there if you if you're watching on the
youtube channel um
okay so we'll get into that in just one
second do want to let you know that you
know
you're listening to a podcast which
means that you might listen to other
podcasts and you're listening to
podcasts that have us on them which may
mean that you want to listen to other
podcasts that have us on them well you
know what
we
are on a hot dog is a sandwich the
episode that i made a guest appearance
on talking about my favorite regional
barbecue
that is out right now hot dog is a
sandwich is the mythical kitchen podcast
hosted by josh and nicole over the
mythical kitchen you slang in some hot
takes over there i haven't listened to
it yet yeah strong hot takes with maybe
there's some mustard i don't know uh and
then link is gonna be on the next
episode talking about uh picky eaters
because
you know i know
it's just a coincidence that he has i
know on that particular episode plugged
into that world
let's get into it man let's let's let me
hear your number 10. i want
should i go first i think you should go
first because i know what my number one
is and i'm not self-conscious about it
and that would be a better ending okay
um
number 10
is
311
i'm so glad you did this the 311 album
self-titled 1995. what what we called
their blue album right i think it was
their third album
uh yeah it was the one that got it it
was the one that people cared about uh
okay and this is on the list uh well can
i ask is it on your list it is not on my
list but it should have been okay so the
reason that this is on my list is very
meaningful because this was 1995
we had
not two basically right around the same
time that we started the wax paper dogs
we were beginning to write music i was
learning how to play the guitar again we
told the story before that when we
started the band we were literally doing
things like wearing cowboy hats and
white t-shirts tucked into jeans and
boots and singing together not in
harmony two melodies yeah i can see
clearly now the rain is gone whatever
the actual name of that song is we think
that's that's how we country roads by
john denver and then that's a different
song but we were interested in other
kinds of music we just couldn't play it
or sing it 311 comes out and i remember
literally being in the back of the
church van going on a trip somewhere
and listening to 311 on my headphones
and trying to teach myself how to play
drums while listening to 311 which
incidentally i figured out how to do the
keep the hi-hat rhythm not that i'm a
drummer
while listening to 311 but it was really
it was influencing the way
that we thought about music
and also i think if you if you could
unearth some of those wax paper dog song
we've only found one
um you would see that we weren't doing a
great job of emulating what they were
doing but it was just like it was the
reason that we had bleached hair and
shaved heads and earrings and big jeans
oh yeah was what they were doing we
changed a lot and then
some some
know that we have always been
down down
if i ever didn't thank you
then just let me do it now this is what
i could not do i couldn't give you one
lyric from this album so that's down
that was a song that was on the radio
and it just blew my it was a
hybridization
i mean so much of what it was truly
innovative
a mythical approach to things not just
food but obviously food has been how we
like to hybridize things
and uh maybe 311 deserves a little bit
of credit because
uh that's why we were we had the
confidence to shift it's like hey we
like rap
we can do it on our
our
like distorted guitar terms
we can
but i will say just quickly definitively
this i'll do this at the end of every
one of these
it does not hold up
i i've tried to i've tried to listen to
it with my kids i've done that with
every single one of these albums
and i'll especially shepherd because me
and shepherd
share a lot of musical taste and
it just it doesn't there's a couple of
good songs and then a lot of like what
is happening here and why is he saying
that what he's saying it was 1995 when
you could say anything in a song lyrics
it just as long as it was words it was
okay yeah so give him a little grace
there but it just it doesn't hold up
musically in my opinion but it for the
time and what it meant to me
it's on the list it can be cringy
especially with like
i'm some people may level some sort of
reggae approaching there's definitely
some appropriations happening there okay
i'm gonna give you my number 10
which
this is so meaningful to me it had to be
on the list because it is the first
album that i ever purchased of course i
purchased it on tape
in 1988 after going over to your house
and seeing that you had his previous
albums and hey as a 10 year old
there's nothing better than like really
silly funny songs
and not only is it making my top 10 list
for being
the first tape i ever owned i still have
it
weirdo yankovic even worse
this is the
i'm i kept the tape all these years
since i was 10 years old look at this
does it have any notes inside and the
liner notes of course the
the album art is um
weird al yankovic
uh impersonating michael jackson in his
bad
uh era and i don't i'm not referring to
anything that came out about him later
i'm talking about
uh his album called bad
um
yeah because the first album that i ever
bought had buckles all over it zippers
okay actually his head's
weird outs had buckles all over it and i
guess that was the joke
i never got that until now
it's not zippers it's buckles i never
saw that i i really
regret not bringing this in and having
weirdos sign it when he was on our show
but it you know uh it had
fat
on it it had stuck in a closet with
vanna white i don't remember many of
these songs i didn't listen to it that
much i just listened to
fat a lot because that was the single
well you're going to be surprised
because you know my first weird album
that i ever bought was weirdo in 3d and
it's not in my top 10. and the only
reason it's on my honorable mentions the
only reason i didn't put it in my top 10
is because i just categorize weird out
in a different place as because because
it's parody music and it means a lot to
me and it helped influence the way that
we think about music and the fact that
we do comedy music so it probably should
be on my top ten but for some reason it
just felt like
because listen i want you to be a little
and you want my weird out that's cool
he's like so he may so
weird al in 3d made my honorable
mentions but not my top ten
give me a number nine
um number nine
i'm assuming that this artist is on your
list but probably not this album number
nine for me is john mayer's continuum
okay um
now let me be clear
this phase so this is 2006 i wasn't into
john mayer in the room for squares
right me neither uh continuum was my
like all of a sudden
i just was like this guy is doing
something that i absolutely
love musically now i actually prefer
the next phase of john mayer's music
yeah
uh paradise valley valley that's like
those like three sort of kind of country
albums that's the john mayer that's my
favorite even more so than the latest
john mayer which i would still love but
the album itself that is uh for me
is a musical masterpiece and i can
listen to it at any time except for that
one jimi hendrix cover
like uh bold is love honestly i'm like
i lose a little interest okay well yeah
i'm not okay that's not everything it's
a little too blue but everything yeah i
mean i'm pretty sure it was nominated
for album of the year
uh
but it didn't win the grammy
but it was i mean waiting on the world
to change
uh
not not my favorite song belief
belief is an interesting song to listen
to because our beliefs have changed
since we first they were starting to
change when we
started to
when when that came out but they've
completely changed now it's yeah i think
about that line uh
belief is beautiful armor but it makes
for the heaviest sword like punching
underwater you never can't hit what
you're
trying for right yeah i mean he's got a
he's got a way with words you know he's
going to show up on my list so i'm going
to uh i'm going to step back on this one
but it is a good vultures is my favorite
song on it well it's just it's a
you know a lot of the things that made
my list are things that when i listen to
them
it's you know how every once in a while
you see a movie and you're like this
changes things for me in the way that i
think about movies yeah and again as an
adult it was kind of difficult it was
easy to do that as a kid and some of the
albums on this list changed the way i
thought about music like that's why 311
made the list
but for me this was like i haven't
really been listening to
anything but country and rap for most
like growing up a lot you know yeah and
and and all of a sudden it was like this
is
like blues rock i don't know how i would
even categorize it but all of a sudden
i'm on board you know yeah and i've kind
of been on that train
for a while
um
all right
i'll talk about my number eight but
first let's promote some merch you got a
nice looking shirt on uh outlook
mythical
you know it's like a magic eight ball
you want to make your life better do you
want to see everything or the lens of
mythicality well
you can make some personal changes in
your life and when you or you can just
short circuit that and just buy a
t-shirt
at mythical.com when you shake it gives
you a new answer yeah ask a question
uh should
you buy this t-shirt
outlook mythical go to mythical.com
rep your boys
all right my number nine is
right here
for every man
by jackson brown released in 1973 this
is his
uh second album and then i mean this is
his parents house on the cover of this
thing it's like this
uh
this grotto looking situation then when
you pull out the album sleeve he's gone
he's gone i know you love
jackson brown jackson brown jackson
brown is on my honorable mentions but it
didn't did not make my uh
did not make my top 10. there's famous
people all over this album you got you
got bonnie rate you've got
you got some eagles playing in here he
co-wrote take it easy with glen frye
and released it on this album the the
eagles also released that song on their
debut album and that's that's the
version that everybody knows but this
album really flows man
it's such a good album from start to
finish but the reason why this is on my
list
is because
when i was working at ibm
uh as an industrial engineer
i'm i was friends with another guy who
we co-op together and then we both got
full-time jobs
and he became kind we connected over
music and
he introduced me to a lot of music he
was like my musical sherpa
if you met him you only met this guy in
passing matt hungate i don't know if the
name rings a bell for you but shout out
to matt hungate we have fallen out of
touch and man i just
i owe you so much for all the music that
you introduced me to and we would
connect over and this was we would talk
about this album what the songs meant
and
it's so this is a combination of
this could potentially be in one of my
favorite albums even now i mean it's a
it's it's just an amazing
experience i like
i just the vibe of it is great and of
course jackson brown has it's
is such a good songwriter the dude you
look is layers and layers of what you
can discover from from this guy and one
of the things he'd like to do what you
did on this album is he had these songs
that had this really
pronounced innuendo redneck friend the
one on this album elton john played
piano on that but what's the one about
uh
his hand uh
that's not on rosie rosie so anyway like
because because you know my
father-in-law introduced me to jackson
brown and he would play that song and he
would be like what do you think this is
about it's like it's like a test
and then if the answer was well this
this song is about masturbation uh
i didn't want the conversation to end in
that way
but no i would put jackson brown
on my top 10 best artists of all
favorite artists without a doubt he's
he's so good you can still go out and
see him you know what around here my
wife was at the the largo
uh for the
they had like a bluegrass thing like the
guy i don't know the guy from the uh i
know you know that old that bluegrass
band
was doing like a a weekly thing and then
all of a sudden jackson brown comes out
and not cool on
you know it's like a crowd of like 200
250 people and jesse's a huge fan so i
was mad that i didn't go that night that
won't prop up but it's it's cool to have
somebody in your life that introduces
you to new music
and you know not having an older brother
your older brother was that for
for me and for you in a lot of ways
especially when it came to the gangsta
rap of the late 80s
what's your number eight um my number
eight
is southeastern by jason isbell okay
2013. now jason isabelle is probably
my favorite artist currently making
music
uh
i think he as john mayer said is the
best lyricist of our age
uh he said that yeah he said jason
isabelle is the best lyricist of our age
i heard it the first time and uh i think
i without a doubt i agree with that like
if you just listen to the things that
this man says in his music
no one else is doing it now in musically
i think it's great as well i love
watching him i love seeing him in
concert but so it was difficult to just
narrow it down to one album but you have
to so
southeastern and then something more
than free are like
sort of like representing the new era
when he he left the drive by well he was
always kind of doing his own thing with
the 400 unit which is his band but he
was also in the drive by truckers and i
don't know exactly the timeline i was
not a fan of the drive-by truckers
at all musically a little too rocky but
then the story goes that he basically
kind of sobered up and got got himself
straight and then started making this
music
uh starting with southeastern being the
first album kind of after that time and
so this album is like intensely personal
and it's just i mean i can just go back
to this i mean and jason isabelle is a
family favorite so some of the ones on
this list one of the reasons is because
every single person in my family
loves to listen to this music and so
this music will be playing in our house
all the time so jason isabel's playing
in the house all the time
um
but yeah if you haven't familiarized
yourself with what's in now he won i
can't remember which album he won a
grammy freak it was southeastern for
best americana album
which is a sore spot for me at least and
probably for jason as well because
i think the easiest way for me to sum it
up is what he's doing is too good for
country music what he's doing is too
good for nashville now he also is pretty
outspoken and his politics are not
really in line with what most country
music is
but
he got he gets categorized as amer
americana he's making country music he's
just making really really really good
soulful introspective thoughtful
meaningful country music and uh
southeastern number eight boy this is
going to be a really good one-two punch
with my number eight um
you texted me one day i was at home
it was a saturday morning i was just
putting around the house
and you said
you got to listen to this album
i didn't realize that
like weeks earlier we had actually gone
to amoeba
record store i'm pretty sure it was me
and you and we had seen this album okay
yep and then i went back home and i
didn't ever listen to it and i don't
know if that's what prompted you to
listen to it uh seeing it and discussing
the album cover but when you texted me
this album i immediately started playing
it right there and i just
i was standing behind my couch
and listening on my speakers and
i had like
it was almost like as
the most spiritual like a purely musical
experience can be like i can't i can't
remember being so floored
by
an artist in a particular album ever i'm
surprised this is your number eight
yeah because i'm definitely building it
up but i was i know what you're gonna i
was absolutely floored from from the
first
like note that he sung
and then all the way through the album
as an entire experience
it was what i was always hoping to find
and becoming convinced that it would
never exist
because of course it's an idea that
people might have
to try to do this type of thing
i'm talking about
sturgill simpson y'all all right this is
his second album meta modern sounds and
country music
you can you can see why we're drawn to
the album cover because it's got it's
got this mixture of
um
uh astral
projection
like cosmos superimposed with old
uh portraiture well but you know you
know the the real story of how we got
introduced both to sturgill simpson and
jason is belt
shout out to matt harmon
oh you think he did that i i know for a
fact that matt
sent me a text
um and was like and both sergil simpson
and jason isabel were recommended in the
text and i had never heard of either one
of them
so
actually matt harmon has
done a lot for you know you're talking
about math he's a sharp i guess you got
to be named you got to be a mat yeah but
uh he's done a lot for me now he's got
some recommendations that i don't always
i'm like okay now i see where our taste
is he goes into this genre deeper and uh
but but sturgeon and jason this is my
pick
this is my picture i'm talking about
matt
matt
has done a lot for me musically turtles
all the way down is the um
i mean the the main single you might
remember but you know it's
at first i was like this guy is
channeling wayland's vocals and
merle sensibility with some george jones
uh inflection like i don't know it just
brought together everything i loved
about classic country into an album
where he had things to say and he had an
experience that he wanted to convey he
was talking about experiences he's had
and conclusions he's come to but then he
presented it sonically in a way that
takes you
on a journey and this so this is another
one of those places that overlaps with
one of my this is my favorite three
you're number three so i need to talk a
little bit more about it before you take
it off the table because you're taking
one of my top three out so it is your oh
you're not going to come back to it
yeah we don't yeah let's see if we have
crossover we talk just like when we do
movies you talk about it at that moment
hopefully you won't take my number one
uh so yeah i can see this being your
number three again if this was my
favorite albums i think it would be
higher now again but not most meaningful
i am a bigger fan of the body of work of
jason isbell than i am of sergio simpson
i just connect more with with jason's
music on a
uh
on a more consistent level with
everything that he does sturgill goes
into the bluegrass stuff which i'm kind
of like i kind of just tolerated i'm not
a huge fan of bluegrass
but is this album this album is a
perfect album and the fact the subject
matter that he is willing to take on
again i think one of the reasons i'm
drawn to to sturgill and to jason and i
don't have anybody except maybe some old
people that we'll talk about
in terms of people making country music
today i don't want to hear you talk
about a tractor or your beer or your
friday night like that kind of [ __ ] i
get it and i respect it but that's not
what i am interested in hearing people
sing about it because that's what people
are all singing about on the radio
everybody's doing the same songs over
and over again these guys are talking
about real stuff
i mean sturgel's talking about
psychedelic drug experiences and he's
putting it into
a perfect country song it's wild and
he's also talking about questioning the
foundations of reality and your the
faith and the worldview that you were
brought up with i mean you know i'm
saying so i think that
it's just it was bold and it was as far
it was as authentic of a throwback as
you can be
coupled with as innovative as a message
as you can have
you put those two things together you
get a number three you get number three
for me now this reminds me we're not
playing any of this music um
i wish we could you know i if if we
could solve that problem
in an elegant way
then
you know i'd i'd be doing a listening
party with britain a lot more i would be
i would be coming up with music
programming
for you mythical beast
um but we just can't
there's no elegant solution that
there are solutions but none of it's
coming together so what we're doing for
this is we're respecting the opinions of
our lawyers
and we you know we want artists to
benefit if you if you play their music
and that's really the crux of it so
what we're going to do is create a
playlist of one track from each of these
albums in the order that we're
presenting them to you on our spotify
account the retin link account so
we'll tweet that out but if you go to
the ret and link
spotify account and then look at our
playlist there there's other playlists
too but this would this will be one of
them all right we'll probably just pick
like the biggest single you know from
each one of those albums all right so
number eight you're number three
sorry for stealing your thoughts this
has got to be on your list i don't know
what number it is number seven
dj jazzy jeff and the fresh prince he's
the dj i'm the rapper 1988. yeah here it
is right here i've i found this record
at like some some weird shop in highland
park and i was like i got a guy i got to
get it even though they're charging like
like 35 for this thing
uh
first thing i you know on the tape it's
it's not quite as obvious but it's it's
just jeff just jeff on the front you got
to turn this thing over and with the
tape
you turn it over and i can't remember
exactly how you think you think will
smith's all about will smith well in his
seminal album he's not even on the
freaking cover he starts with he's like
hey he's the dj i'm the rapper now i
think that this was so significant for
both of us
what number is it for you this is my
number five okay so at least 17 88. so
the reason that this is so significant
for me is now we talked a little bit
about like my brother introducing us to
to rap and specifically gangsta rap and
like nwa straight up out of compton that
kind of thing yeah none of that made my
list
and one of the reasons is is it was
too much for me at the time i loved it
it was scandalous i had no idea what
they were talking about but i had no
idea what they were talking about i was
a little white
christian kid in the middle of bowie's
creek north carolina it don't matter
just don't bite what i didn't understand
anything that they were talking about
and they were rebelling against but the
thing that will smith very very
uh astutely understood is that
he could make this and i don't know what
where his mind was at but what he ended
up doing was he created something that
kids of
all shades all across america would be i
remember when linwood campbell stood up
in the bus on a field trip
and wrapped parents just don't
understand word for word
i was like
that was my introduction i was like
lynnwood what was that
yeah i was like that was the coolest rap
in the funniest rap and the most
relatable rap that i've ever heard in my
entire life it was fun it connected with
a middle schooler it it had a sense of
humor
the entire album i mean you got
nightmare on my street where it's like
this story about
him
him coming downstairs and freddy
krueger's watching letterman on his
couch yeah and we and they were a duo
you know what i'm saying yeah and i
think that that connected with us as
well in fact during that time so this is
88 is when we were inventing our
rap alter ego and i was m.c skye and
that was dj strawbeat and i have no clue
what that means
straw beat
yeah i don't know m c sky just meant i
was tall and i was an emcee i wanted i
wanted to be the dj because i don't know
i was just drawn to that role and you
know what they gave him props on this
album maybe i'll get on the album cover
if i'm the dj i mean
that was
so much for that dj djs were the center
of hip hop and then over time it became
about it became about the emcee but like
smart mcs would always
give their dc props and that's why he's
on the front of this album yeah because
i think will smith knew that he was this
let's talk about the sky the sky is the
limit for this guy i mean look at him
now i also
i also find like this inspiration from
the fact that he was a kid when he made
this album there's this crazy story
of him going broke after experiencing
the success and the touring of this and
then
he was completely broke when he tells
the story of
quincy jones giving him the opportunity
to make make the fresh prince of bel-air
you should google
i don't know what you would google but
just google
will smith
tells the story of the fresh prince of
bel-air you let him tell it it's a great
story on youtube um and and again
is it so
i haven't been doing this with
everything but this it doesn't hold up
okay i actually listened to it last
night
and uh it was so
much of the time
that it's it's it's so cheesy it's i
mean it's just so cheesy that our tastes
have changed so much but hold on but
let's get some good you listen there's
some good tracks well but if you listen
to straight outta compton now
it still
totally hits like i mean it's it's not
every single one but yeah but you're
like yeah yeah like but this is
interesting
you're kind of laughing at this when you
go back you know but at the time it was
it was the perfect recipe
uh for for kids and ready rock c their
beat boxer was considered part of the
group back then
but yeah i mean there's a couple of
like time to chill got a great sample
yeah it's really once he starts rapping
that you're like
this is not this isn't the way people
rap anymore and it's kind of hard to
listen to it's endearing but yeah it's
just nostalgic at this point but it was
my number five because as a ten-year-old
like having that little tape like dual
tape deck where you're recording stuff
off the radio and when you do buy an
album you you buy it wherever you can
get it it's like mom's not going to take
me all the way to raleigh to buy an
album every weekend to buy tape i went
to the tmart
in anger
with my grandma just to get some fried
chicken
and right at the they had tapes right at
the counter and they had this tape and i
bought it and i listened to that thing
religiously and i
memorized every single bit of it like i
was just obsessed with it and it
like it was i wanted to be them so badly
at that time and that's why we were we
were writing wraps and we were like
doing the talent show thing and and
wrapping them on the playground it was
all because of them and then i
discovered
when i think cole
did he have the cd
this was he yeah it might have been a
tape i don't think so um
i was listening he was listening to it
at his house and i realized
his
his tape or whatever it was had twice as
many songs on it as mine yeah because
there's the the extended version that's
got like 20 songs or something no i had
bought a bootleg tape from tmart and
they weren't they were so lazy they
didn't even put all the songs on it
it was xeroxed like the cover was black
and white okay yeah you got a boot
it was like shady it was like dot matrix
printed black and white cover like i
just thought that's what it was
and i saw the real thing yeah but it
does have a lot of how many songs does
it have on it i don't know a lot it
doesn't list them on the back because
fresh prince takes up the whole thing
okay
it is two records what's your number
seven okay yeah i'm going backwards in
my number seven this is the only record
that i don't own that maybe i need to
buy because i mean it is my i'm putting
it in my number seven this one's a
little tenuous but it doesn't mean a lot
to me from 1997
surfacing by sarah mclaughlin
whoa
[Laughter]
i mean i know you know this well
she's like you know i love her and
listen to but singles i got compilation
i didn't i couldn't even have named the
album what what song is that is your
love is better than ice cream on that
album no that's that's the next that's a
good song though this one's got building
a mystery
sweet surrender and
eddie i do believe i failed you
yeah yeah you know it was great uh it's
it's got i don't know how well it holds
up but i think it does it's definitely
like got this strong
90s
vibe and you the production is very
assertive in like this ethereal
moody way
that
even though it came out in 1997 so we
were you know
freshman year
leaving high school going off to college
um by junior year i mean it was just a
it was something it was an album that i
kept going back to
and did you get this like bmg music or
something uh
most likely yeah because that's how but
you liked it and i think you may have
introduced me to it i love sarah because
like you and greg love jewel and like
these female singer songwriter types of
that era
what we we really said you know what
we're going we started eating that stuff
up yeah um jewel pieces of you now that
you said that that is a good album i
don't know that should be that should be
on my list it's not it's such a delicate
album but if you listen to it now which
i actually recently did i listened to
that song about adrian oh that's sad and
also you forget how the choices that
artists would make the way that she's
sang
it's like nails on a chalkboard now like
you won't be able to take it if you
listen i mean this you can definitely
take and so by the time
uh christy went away
for the summer before our senior year
and that's when
i we're having a long distance
relationship all summer and i was trying
to
figure out and go through my systems to
like understand if we should be married
if i wanted to
propose to her and of course by the end
of the summer i did like the day she got
home
i've told that story before of us
getting engaged but this album
i kept going back to it because
emotionally
it was where i was like it was just kind
of like this it wasn't about the lyrics
as much as just the vibe of just
it kind of had this aching
sensation to it that
i just wanted to sit there and listen to
the entire album and just
ache
with missing christy and just feel it
well she's like this is what i kept
going back to she's the like the queen
of melancholy i i tend to be pretty
melancholy and i remember when when
we were getting ready to move into
the house in chapel hill and i was doing
the drywall downstairs to like turn the
basement into like a livable space and i
did all the drywall myself uh-huh
never will do that again but that
drywall is multiple steps
and i had a compilation that had sarah
mclaughlin and tori amos
and some other
very like just some just some sad
melancholy you know sit down there and
like sand
sand the seams on the uh
probably really
but yeah if i listen to it now it takes
me back to laying on like i took a trip
to wisconsin and i was like couch
surfing
and
i remember sleeping on the floor and
just putting this music on and just
just
concentrating all of my
attention on
missing christy
and so now when i listen to this album
it transports me back there and it's
that's the experience i get and that's
that's why
it's number seven because
it's that that moment of
i've got a big decision to make and my
heart already knows the answer
my head's really getting in the way and
i so it's actually a good reminder when
i go back and like listen to this album
that like
i could be more in touch with my heart
and
uh
and adopt enjoy myself a little bit
a pet from a shelter
[Laughter]
my number six
is
billy joel innocent man 1983.
this album is a musical masterpiece i
think it goes without saying
uh but for me
this is you know that okay i'm six years
old when this thing comes out
i'm really getting into it when i'm like
seven eight nine
it was
the sit in your room
and sing
with billy joel it was the
first time that i'm like
completely
unself-consciously like just
putting in the jam box and just singing
so it's like it's just so good and first
of all this was sort of the convergence
for me i didn't know by the way that he
did all the parts he tracked all those
vocals until like a couple months ago
this was the convergence of
mtv and
having the music you remember the music
video for that i remember the white
t-shirts uptown girl it's it's you know
the the whole album and again i didn't
understand enough about music to know
that he had made a decision
to move into this doo-wop 50s throwback
place
so in other words like you've got john
mayer today
in 2021 going back to kind of the 80s
you know what i'm saying you go back 30
years or so well in in the 80s billy
joel was going back 30 years to the 50s
and bringing back this do up thing which
i didn't un i didn't make the connection
even though my parents had like frankie
valley records and stuff that i would
listen to i was just like i love what
this guy is doing
and he also has that he sort of sings
with a little bit of a air you know he
he's got that like he has things with a
little bit of an awesome battle with the
clothes i'm
not
until available didn't start the fire i
mean i followed him into the fire okay
and then after that is when i kind of
stopped following him yeah but this i
think this is just the definitive album
for me in the way that it changed my
relationship
with music and that it became something
that i would sit in my room and i would
sing
do you know what i'm saying like you you
there there was some music at the time
that
i couldn't really i couldn't really sing
along with in in
not that i was sounding good when i was
singing along with billy joel but it was
just like this is it gets into your soul
and you want to sing you want to dance
have you gone back and listened to that
album
like in it start to finish yeah recently
uh last year
on a trip um
road trip somewhere
i was like let's listen to
this album that was one of my favorite
albums as a kid start to finish and we
did and like i knew that shepard would
be into it
and i would say that
i didn't immediately say to myself man i
got to keep going back and listening to
billy joel it wasn't like now i continue
to go back and listen to that album
so
i do now first of all it's timeless
music it was timeless when it came out
it's still timeless so it does hold up
uh some of the songs do but
i don't know it's just something it does
i don't connect with it in the same way
that i that i used to and my kid in in
shepherd will like
listen to like shepherd still listens to
elton john as an example like and he's
incorporated elton john into his cool
songs playlist on spotify nice but he
hasn't incorporated
maybe
maybe piano man i think maybe is on that
list but like he hasn't gotten a lot of
yeah a lot of billy joel in the on the
list i'll talk to him about it maybe
it'd be better coming from uncle link
not that he would ever ever calls me
that
can you get him to call me that no okay
i can't even get him call me dad
uh so i'm at my number six this is gonna
be
where i bring in the fleet foxes
and i've i've picked helplessness blues
from 2011.
oh look at that look at that cover boy
that's hipster
boy
look at that look at the back look at
these hipsters right there even got
father john misty playing the drums on
this album what the crap
yeah man for real right down there
yeah that's him in the corner i believe
um
so i was introduced
to
fleet fox's
uh keena grannis
yeah you know start started out on
youtube as a musician she covered uh
the
white the white hymnal song it's i'm
missing a word from the title i can't
remember it but that was on a previous
album
and i'm like this song is amazing why do
i not know about this and like i
discovered
fleet foxes and then but this album is
special to me because
um when it came out in 2011
we were i was i was anticipating it
because i just gotten into them and
there's nothing more thrilling than
really getting into an artist that a has
a body of work that you can get into
or if they're a current artist
that they're about to release a new
album so it's like i'm getting in and
the wave is still
crescendoing this album is is great yeah
um
from from from start to finish
i can't tell you the names of any of the
songs i can't tell you half of what he's
talking about but it's it's it evokes
nature
and it evokes uh on a
unlike uh a gut level
i is how i describe it and you know he's
he's from seattle he's um
robin pecnold the guy who's like
basically
writing these songs and and
orchestrating all these harmonies and
everything but for me i associate this
with
our our move to california i remember
when this album came out
we were filming commercial kings
and we had shot
the episode with chuck testa
and then we had to get up
the next morning and we had rental cars
it was like me and you and daniel are
like director and still good friend
daniel strange he was in the back seat
me and you were in the front seat
we were talking about music this album
had just come out i hadn't had a chance
to listen to it so my first experience
of listening to this album was driving
from ojai california
on two-lane roads like winding roads
through
the mountains of california to try to
get up to reno reno for the roller for
the roller coaster and um so yeah just
so you know the the chuck testa
commercial and the roller kingdom
commercial were both shot during the
same like trip then four five days of
each other yeah the same in the same
five days but when we were driving
it was
like it kind of felt like
you you put them you put your
destination into google maps and then it
sends you on this road that ends up
being a private road that literally i
felt we were driving through washes
where the road would go down into
whether i remember this when it was a
flash flood like the stream would come
across the the road and you would have
to turn around if that happened and
drive like four hours to go another
route to get to where you were going but
it was absolutely beautiful
daniel got sick and had to go to sleep
in the back seat because it was so the
road was so windy but
when i listened to this
song yeah it already evokes nature
but it evokes that imagery of driving
through california we had just moved
we were still even calling it temporary
but
this this sound
is now associated to me with california
because there's so much nature that
we've experienced here and i fleet foxes
is always a part of that
for me and um it really opened up that
entire genre that is now
like a bucket that i keep filling where
like whether that's
you know going back to some bonivare or
like really get into lord huron
it it this this was the uh
this is the watershed moment really this
album and it that i can experience
that drive that we had
and we were being so creative and like
there was so much of our future ahead of
us and it was actually working we took a
huge risk moving to california we were
making a television show that we
believed in
and for the first time and it was so
exciting so all of that is wrapped up in
uh this album from me and puts it at
number six yeah there's a there it's a
it's more of vibe yeah than it is uh an
earnestness and a clarity which i think
you'll see once i get to my number one
that like i i'm finding and seeing
myself i love fleet foxes and lord huron
and that vibe to listen to that music
maybe more than anything besides like a
jason isabel at this point
but the cl the sort of the clarity and
the earnestness of like
what is being said and like you can
understand the lyrics yeah as a value
for me that i don't that i think that i
have
underestimated until i put the list
together right because this is for me
this is a vibe
and musically it's like some of the best
music that's been made in the past 20
years
but i didn't put you know it's not on
the list because it feels like i can't
tell you what he's talking about and
yeah and i don't know why that that's
how i interpret it and that that is a
difference like for me it's like having
having a vibe and the melodies and
definitely having a hook and definitely
having especially if you're throwing in
harmonies
uh
then i'm done it's like i'll figure out
what the what the message later taking a
little bit of it or never a left turn um
and again
this is th this is the disclaimer of
when i begin to get self-conscious about
my list but i cannot and i had to put
him at number five garth brooks
garth brooks
that's the album self-titled 1989 is
that so that's his first album what's on
that so this is like it's not no fences
no so i couldn't it got down to garth
brooks and no fences and because no
offenses is huge like friends in low
places yeah garth brooks
he was like mega star but i was trapped
in that but but i looked at both both
track lists and i was like which one did
you really end up listening to
the most and i think it's garth brooks
garth brooks it's a little bit
unpolished now first of all
you know there's a lot to say about
garth brooks and chris gaines
uh we won't say anything about chris
gaines
but wow i never saw garth in concert and
i understand that like oh he puts on an
amazing show i don't care it's i i would
we didn't care we went to some shows but
we didn't care about i wouldn't care
about garth brooks concert i don't care
that he's going to be like on a harness
like is this slightly dad bod dude like
going up a ladder and coming down on a
harness i'm not shameless up here on
this
cable there's a whole lot about
garth brooks that is embarrassing to me
and embarrassing to this day and i mean
you're not a fan of the man you're a fan
of the music well no and there's this
whole thing i don't know if you've seen
it you know uh oh i've seen we were on
tom segura's uh podcast i love what he's
and you know what he's doing tomorrow's
like whole army
has flooded all the garth brooks of
social media with like theories about
garth hiding bodies and murdering people
because garth has this obviously
somebody was getting him to do social
media kind of feel to all his stuff
anyway i find all that hilarious but
garth is inclusive go go i i think he's
coming out i mean i think i saw him on a
billboard talking about inclusivity and
the lbgtq all that stuff yeah i don't
know about it i mean i don't know
anything about modern garth i think the
way i said it is the way that garth is
saying you know all that stuff if that's
true
that's true that's awesome i think he's
four but i'm talking about the fact that
growing up listening to country music
that was on the radio and not really
being a fan of anybody who was really
doing anything currently and again
some sometimes people come along and
there's this seminal moment where all of
a sudden you're like this is different
this is being done on a different level
now you go back and l i don't go back
and listen to any garth brooks mostly
because he's not on spotify i mean the
dude's not even on spotify you got to go
to amazon and this is like relatively
recent like just in the past few years
you can listen to him on amazon
unlimited music which i don't i guess if
i'm prime do i have i don't know i'm not
interested i don't that's not how i do
it so he's kind of held out
so i don't really listen to him my
suspicion is you know garth has never
been an incredible singer you know
that's not what he's known for
uh
again i wasn't impressed with the
performance it's just something about
the time the place that i was at as a
kid you loved it you know in
1989 i'm 12 years old
you know i've been sitting in my room
singing billy joel for years i'm ready
to sing something else
and i remember
uh this isn't on that album but there's
a dream is like a river that song which
is no fences or one after i don't know
he made a bunch of stuff in the 90s
and like
i would be driving with my family and
the song would come on and like my dad
would be like right sing this one for us
like literally like i'd be like in the
back i'd be in the back seat singing for
the family another dream is like a river
like really trying to get it just right
ever changing it as it flows you know
and it's like the dance is there's just
yeah the dance is a hard song to sing
even for garth
but it just
it was just just you know it's that
timing of something that immediately
you're like find yourself
thinking about these songs singing these
songs on a regular basis there was an
emotional quality to it yeah that had no
one had really done in country country
was about bar rooms and drinking and all
of a sudden you got this guy who comes
along and he's like i'm going to talk
about how
this
the life the life of a cowboy but from
this introspective place and maybe
people were doing it before that but i
didn't hear it until garth
yeah his name was garth do you think it
was a little more writerly
i do think that
yeah i i knew that you would have garth
on your list man all right so my number
five we've already talked about uh he's
a dj i'm the rapper
which brings me to my number four
well should i didn't do my number four
so we can keep it the pace to go because
because we've also talked about my
number three already
okay so you've talked about my number
four so i'll just i'll just um yeah give
me your number give me your number four
my number four now okay so we talked
about this ahead of time so i don't know
i thought the plan was we were each
gonna pick a merle haggard album
right so this is my merle haggard album
that i have chosen okay all right so one
of the things that we we talked about
the fact that we were not introduced to
merle in album form we were introduced
to merle through a compilation
uh
marlboro country my dad had which was
literally an album that a cigarette
company put out
and it had a couple of merle songs on it
i think okay from muskogee and rambling
fever is what i remember maybe that's
not right i remember i wish a buck was
still silver and so then we ended up
getting murl albums but then making
merle compilation albums which we talked
about in the book of mythicality where i
would sit there and like
come up with like merle wall-to-wall
wall-to-wall merle wall
and so
that's how i've always experienced merle
and he's got so much music that even to
this day when i go back and i look at an
album that comes out in that era that's
my favorite era which is late 70s early
80s i'll be like oh there's like two
songs on this album i don't think i've
ever heard right
but so but i have made an effort in the
past few years to be like okay spotify
makes it easy i can just listen to the
whole album yeah and so in my effort to
narrow it down to what i think is my
favorite merle album
i waffled back and forth but i landed on
1979 serving 190 proof can't argue with
that one man that is i would agree that
is his that is my favorite album of
merle's
it's a it's a great album of course
footlights is on that which we covered
on on our our mythical society record
and we we performed on tour uh with
britain playing the yeah nailing the
guitar solo
um
yeah i mean i i got more to say about
merle i want to save it okay because
it's you know i it's a higher number for
me and i want it to be commensurate with
that discussion since you stole my
thunder for both of these now i'm giving
you my number four
which for me is
continuum so i didn't talk about it when
you did because i didn't know that's
what we were doing oh wow i chose
continuum because
uh
when we
it this is about
family for me like when you're talking
about jason isabel and how your family
all listens to him and is a fan of his
because that's what's playing in the
house
for for us that's definitely john mayer
i mean we went you we went to the his
show uh pre-pandemic
at the forum and um
coach you were there yeah and britain
was there but
uh all of my family was there except for
lando because he really didn't want no
lando was there and he fell asleep it's
like my whole family was there because
we were all such big fans of i think my
kids were there too john mayer i think
at least one of them
jesse wasn't there jesse didn't come
yeah um going to that show represented
how important like his music was to our
entire family and then when we got there
what we didn't know was on that
particular night it was like an
anniversary of the release of continuum
so he played the entire album from start
to finish and that was the only night as
far as i know that he did that on the
entire tour even though he was playing
the forum again the next night he didn't
do it again there either right
so that was like
a huge treat
and it was something that we experienced
as a family and then when we you know
over the course of the pandemic he was
doing his instagram live stream show
current mood and
lily and i especially connected over
that and we would build our schedule
around watching it
and
i we just connected so much with what he
was doing and the fact that he was
talking about his experience and
connecting with people's experience
you know dealing with
coronavirus and what that meant
socially and emotionally
uh mentally but yeah i had to pick this
album and i put it at number four
because it's meant so much to me and
lily's relationship and
uh
really our entire family and so now when
i go back to this album it not only
takes me to that show but it takes me to
our experience as a family going through
uh quarantine
and i kind of
if i have my way i could i would bookend
it with the cybrok album which kind of
you know this is this is on the front
side of the pandemic for us
and then
and it was something i was already
passionate about but then on the back
end he releases his new album and that's
something we got to experience too i had
already recommended it my number four
wow okay well i i get that i and if i
was talking if we were talking just
best music like from a musical
standpoint
that's it that's got to be
top five
um
okay so we've already talked about my
number three which was the meta modern
sound coaching music search did you know
that so then i need to talk about my
number three yeah did you know that uh
i didn't i actually just saw it last
night
uh the stevie wonder
had an album called
modern sounds and country and western
music so sturgill's uh album ray charles
yep ray charles yeah so uh
it's a reference yeah i didn't know it
was a reference to that i thought he
just came up with it uh yeah i didn't
know about that album until
like over the past year somebody was
writing about it
and i was i need to check it out yeah
he's he he plays
it's a country album that ray charles
does that's like
critically acclaimed
so we should both listen to it all right
so my number three
is not
de la soul's balloon mind state but i'm
just making the point that
in this slot this is the album i would
pick as one of my favorites of all time
but what i'm putting as my number three
is a tribe called quest
low end theory
this is an amazing album it came out in
1991.
cole had it
and while we were listening to young mc
and m.c hammer
i would go over to his room and he would
be listening to this and i bought it and
i got obsessed with this album and i
just feel venerated
uh all these years later that like
apparently i did have good taste because
this is an absolute it holds a classic
um
i wouldn't say that it holds up in every
single way if i was being picky but like
it's an ab i mean it's it it basically
does and it's it's a classic musically
to say anything negatively yeah there's
a couple of like
there's a couple of uh
ways that they talk about things mostly
mostly
but may he rest in peace right yeah um
the thing about the low end theory for
me is
we
we were living history like this album
came out cole bought it right then i
heard it i went on and got it i became
obsessed with it and now all these years
later
when there's all these
hip-hop documentaries coming out
and analysis
it people point to how important this
excuse me i'm not i'm not getting
emotional at this point i'm just
literally getting choked up
um
people talk about how classic it is and
we lived it i mean
it wasn't our experience i'd never been
to new york city i'm i'm not a young
black man and i never was
and
but it was it was a privilege
to even be
well outside of the circle of that
experience as just some clueless
white boy
but i'm glad that
i could say that
i did connect with it now part of it at
first was that it wasn't explicit
so i didn't feel guilty about listening
to it and memorizing it and wrapping it
and it so it took the place of a dj
jazzy jeff and the fresh prince in that
way
because i was older and i wasn't going
to be that guy anymore
but
so i could with my conscience intact i
could i could really get into this album
but it really was
like
that's when i started started to
understand how samples worked and
how hip hop was constructed which was
really it's i'm still
fascinated by it i think with the way
that my brain works i'm more of a
an editor and
i don't like to create something from
nothing i like to create
something from something
and
i think that's why i have such a deep
connection to hip-hop because that
that's how they did it
they took what they had and they made it
into something else and
they made an absolute
masterpiece and so now
it's again just the living the history
of it and going back and being able to
celebrate it it's kind of like saying
wow i was there for it at least in my
own
experience you know and it i don't know
it just it ends up meaning so much that
i'm gonna pump that thing all the way up
to
um number three and it informs how i
listen to music now because once you
have an experience of
discovering a classic album along with
when it's released
you have this expectancy that like this
this can happen again
people are releasing albums all the time
and
so it's like if to pimp a butterfly
comes out and you're listening to it
before you people tell you that it's an
instant classic
you're part of a you're part of the
experience yeah so i i think because of
how i experience low end theory now
it is how i experience music in general
with an expectancy
to find those moments where
um
like i described with sturgeon simpson
or the first time i listened to golden
hour by casey musgraves that was like
this
this is going to be a part of my life
forever yeah and i love that feeling and
i give and that's what this album means
to me number three
um
that was an honorable mention didn't
make my list because i didn't feel like
i dug in is deep enough to for it to but
it was that was the sort of the fuel for
our uh talent show uh tribe called quest
was yeah the fuel for our talent show
performances that's right my number two
1994
weezer oh the blue album
uh
again this is a this is very much
middle-aged white guy of you yeah this
is
uh
again i there's that but there's also
again
i think 94 was probably the year we
started the band um yep
and again like the way that they were
thinking about music and
it was it just felt so different than
anything that already happened like you
know nirvana nevermind is on my
honorable mention it would never make my
top ten yeah because it just didn't feel
like it was for me it felt like it was
too rebellious
for this little conservative
christian little white boy in bowie's
creek yeah but weezer felt like okay
yeah i can
you take your car to work it's like i've
never surfed before but like i feel like
this is this subject matter doesn't seem
like he had either
right
um embracing the nerdiness and
the sense of humor it was very
accessible to us and exciting for us in
that way it was some it was simple yeah
it was melodic and that's what drew me
to it it was melodic i i loved what they
were they were doing with you know
rhythmically on the guitars
and then
subject matter
was it's like i don't quite understand
my name is jonas like i don't
i don't think i've ever you know i'm
sure i could listen to it but like i
don't know exactly what's happening here
but like i i could write down what he's
saying and you know you know what i'm
saying yeah you can just so there was a
hear it there was a there's a sort of an
earnestness to
rivers approach to writing lyrics but
again not something i would have said
before this list
that like i end up kind of connecting
with
um but really it was musically what was
happening and it felt like it was a
little bit of a
safe manageable rebellion
in the midst of the where i was again
we're listening to
sort of rap and country
uh rap obviously felt like a rebellion
but country felt like obviously garth
brooks was a super super safe thing that
like my dad could say i like that as
well why don't you why don't you sing
this one rhett but my dad's not going to
ask me to sing
weezer in the backseat i'm just singing
the sweater song song what is that what
is that racket you know
but as this as a southern kid in that
setting who was beginning to play music
and just bought himself this electric
guitar
sitting there and thinking like this
feels like i could do it like i feel i
can do a bar chord here
and then here
i think i'm weezer so so many kids who
were starting bands at that time it
begged thought they were weezer and
thought that they could do what those
guys did every once in a while i can
kind of pick something fast you know so
i just think it was so influential in
what we were trying to do
musically which again a lot of this
translates to
the way i think about
my own music and songwriting you know
what i'm saying which is which is like
how does it translate into the way that
i
think about melody and i think about
rhythm and not like i'm not saying like
hey i'm working on a weezer album but at
the time
that was if i came to you with like this
little riff
i either had 311 or weezer in mind yeah
i was ripping both of them off with a
regular on a regular basis we never gave
pinkerton a chance but i do think that
the blue album holds up
it
it rocked my world when i found out
again this is like two weeks ago
that okay well i don't i don't have this
album this is not on my list but okay
but i am thinking about buying this
album because it i'm now expanding it is
a meaningful album to me for all the
reasons that you said
um
what does the front of the album look
like just from memory all four guys just
standing on a blue background with their
hands in certain positions like behind
them remember anything about their shoes
in my mind they're all cut off cowboy
at the bottom of the record but maybe
i'm wrong about that you're they're cut
off at the ankles
okay yeah
there's a version and i couldn't i i
don't think i could have told you that
but i have no way of knowing because the
thing that rocked my world was the
existence of an album where you can see
their shoes
there is a version that if you want if
you're a collector
it's like an overseas version
it's the same exact album nothing's
different at all except the picture on
the front you can see their shoes and
let me tell you
it was not it's worse like something
about cropping it at the ankles was
brilliant well they all probably had on
like converse all-stars no it was like
it was more fuddy-duddy shoes it's like
the shoes weren't cool and i don't know
if that's the reason you guys cut your
shoes off they were they were uncool and
that made them cool but even they were
was so somebody was somebody somebody
figured out somebody was like your shoes
aren't on so uncool they're cool they're
just so uncool that they we need to cut
them off of them really actually uncool
i would love to get one of those like
that's
that's the hazard of of being a record
collector with my no you got the way
that i think now i got to get that one
my number two
is
released in 1991 rel i think it was
released basically the same time as low
end theory like there's a whole
there's a whole thing about 1991
and the albums that were released that
year like the classic albums
uh
i mean you knew i was gonna pick blood
sugar sex magic by red hot chili peppers
because you know
from the moment
like
give it away came out on mtv
and then and then under the bridge came
out and david rogers performed it at our
eighth grade talent show but he had to
stop
the tape abruptly before the like
all the the backup singers came in
because that would just be weird i'm
done i'm done that's it guys i i was i
was obsessed with this album and it was
it was it was so off limits like i mean
i'm sure there's there was parental
advisory on it and it wasn't that we
didn't listen to a bunch of rap that way
but to listen to a rock album
and to really get into the funk of it
yeah because the only thing we could
have on that list was sugar
right you know we definitely couldn't
have sex or magic i think this is crazy
i think this is the chili peppers fifth
album
definitely definitely their fourth but
it was the first one we got into and
then i i was i've been a dedicated fan
ever since even though you you rip
his lyrics his lyricism apart and i
can't argue with that
i just again i love a vibe and i love a
few incredible and this this this
this means
this is my 16 year old experience
like there's this forbidden world out
there where you you're covered in
tattoos and you're embracing sexuality
and it all comes through
bass guitar
and funk
and it references rap but it does it in
this way that only a guy like rick rubin
could bring together
i mean it's an absolute classic people
people might argue that there are better
chili pepper albums came after this
but
just the raw
creativity that went into this thing
these guys were kids
i mean i went back and listen and and
watched
the documentary that um
they went into harry houdini's the house
that he used to live in and they lived
and recorded this whole album there
and uh
you know they were
you you look at the documentary and
they're just kids
just trying to push
on their wieners coming off the streets
of la and just going
like
going hard on instinct
and if you want to just it's it's a it's
it just transports me to being 16. and i
think that they they really if you take
weezer 311 and you have a third
ingredient to what we were trying to do
as a band red hot chili peppers easily
easily now we they were the most
difficult to pull off
so we never actually did it this was all
you know i was i thought going into this
that
a red hot chili peppers album might be
on my list and then i when i looked at
him i started realizing that i had you
don't actually like you're not actually
a fan i had experienced red hot chili
peppers in single form and i looked at
this album
and i was like man there's probably like
five or six songs on this album that i
don't even know if i've ever heard so i
could i could never say that i
experienced it as an album it was more
like there's like
10 songs from there like the 90s that
are like i really really like and kind
of influenced us but yeah it just wasn't
an album it wasn't an album experience i
mean as a as a fan
to this day i don't
you know i i would put them definitely
notches above what what weezer
accomplished but you know i mean
in terms of a harbinger for 90s
alternative rock
and everything that everything that came
from that movement they were definitely
on the on the they were ahead of that
yeah but um i love it i play it in the
house and
really loudly sometimes and
everybody just kind of leaves the room
um
okay my number one
okay
and by this point you know what my
number one is so we can get into that
well essentially you're self-conscious
actually i don't i i i i feel like i
don't oh it's got it's got to be the
merle album
uh yeah i didn't put again the reason i
didn't
give that spot though even though merle
is my all-time favorite artist is
because again it was difficult to narrow
down to an album yeah this is gonna be a
head scratcher for you i think then
you'll be like oh okay i mean i don't
have a guess uh and again
this is like asking me what my favorite
food is and then it was kind of like
process of elimination and this ended up
being in number one so this is not a
strong number one but
i think my favorite album
of all time for like all the reasons
together
is emotionalism ava brothers
okay
all right all right i did okay
now all right let me let me hear you
okay so first of all uh
again it goes back to what i really
value in music uh the avett brothers
have an earnestness in their
music
that
my honest assessment of where it has
gone to in the past couple albums is
that it's actually gone beyond something
that even i am into yeah like i don't
consider myself a fan of their most
recent work too much like i had to let
go because it got too earnest
but this you know and they do they did
some stuff really early on that was a
little bit like all over the place
musically they were figuring themselves
out emotionalism uh represents for me
the beginning of an era in which they
had it kind of now this is pre rick
rubin but it was like they had it all
locked in in terms of what
the sound was and what the message was
and what the harmonies were i'm a big
fan of them love seeing them live i've
seen them live like on new year's eve a
few times they're from north carolina my
family has probably played more avett
brothers music in the house than anybody
else on this list um
and again there is this sort of like
window of time in which it's like this
is when they were really doing it but i
remember it was actually greg our friend
greg hartsfield who
introduced us to the everett brothers
and he did it with this album and the
first song on emotionalism die die die
die die
which
at the time
you know it so
you're probably better remembering the
exact lyrics but like nobody knows
basically nobody knows what happens
before like they phrase it in a funny
way this basically nobody knows what
happens after you die yeah but
the way that they were talking about
these existential issues in a way that
there was this sort of reverence for
this understanding of
god but also this
sort of bold questioning of certainty
around those things which again this is
i mean 2007
i was beginning to ask some of those
questions and my faith was beginning to
unravel even that long ago right
um but i don't know it's just the the
the heart for me it i'm i'm a huge you
know i'm a musician myself so i
definitely am a
like
when you talk about the different
elements of something musically coming
together
that gets me excited but i think i'm
more of a songwriter than i am a
musician and so that's that's why i'm
going to connect mostly
on an emotional level with when i'm
thinking about the songwriting when i'm
thinking about the message behind it
then if you can bring in
a great packaging for that message
that just makes it better and just
something came together on this album a
little banjo ain't never heard that i
just felt like i just felt like it was
for me you know what i mean like this
this is me kind of personified musically
and they're they're from
similar places as us they're of a
similar age they're they went through
similar phases too because you know had
this really like hard heavy metal sort
of like punk phase yeah like just as you
know musically on their own not as they
as the averett brothers just being
brothers who had a band you know they
were ecu
and they were kind of doing that thing
and then they kind of were like let's go
a little bit back to our roots and let's
when me and you sing harmonies that are
serious harmonies or even
most of our armies are stupid harmonies
stupid songs
like we end up we've been heavily
influenced by the way that they approach
that's my favorite part is the
production and like the blood harmony
yeah i think was something that like it
it did blow me away when i first heard
it and i was like i absolutely love
what they've done
um the first in the first half of that
album
is great
second half loses me a little bit
because it's like it gets a little
aggressive well there's so many songs on
that album that towards the end it's
kind of like it fizzles out you guys
were just kind of throwing demos on the
first half oh i mean especially if you
if because i love those harmonies so
much it's like it really does it didn't
make my list i think i'm overly
influenced by
it was a special time in our lives when
it's like
they brought me back out to seeing shows
too it's like i wanted to see these guys
they're great and it was like oh yeah i
should see other people yeah so but yeah
it was an obsession at a certain point
uh and i and that's the reason why i own
that record because it it it doesn't
mean something to me it's an honorable
mention i for my number one
i had to put
once i started to think about
merle i was like i mean who are we
kidding here and i know you agree with
this that like
he's he means so much to us and to our
friendship that
uh i i had i had to put it on there um
it
we channeled our passion from music
in high school
into merle like we were so
and i think it
it
it coalesced our friendship you know for
sure because because
we would we discovered it and then i
remembered like my aunt vicki had albums
i would borrow those we started going on
when when you started driving and then i
got my license we would go on excursions
to find
another one of his tapes that we hadn't
found yet
and some i remember i remember sometimes
i would i would come home with the tape
and the fir and then i couldn't wait to
get home and call you and tell you
i found a new merle album we there was
no
we had no way of finding out how many
moral albums existed or what they were
called there's no
like there were ways but we didn't know
any of them so i would just the only way
was to go to a store and find it i
remember calling you i found a new merle
tape that i've never seen
it's a it's and it's a complete album
it's not a compilation it's not a
retread it's called out among the stars
and the cover looks horrible it's like
an illustration of him
and then we listened to it and it was
and you try and you're trying to figure
out where it fits in with in this in his
body of work and i'm giving it to you so
that you can add it to compilation tapes
and you're right we didn't end up
listening to
the tapes we would transfer those to
compilations and leave out the songs
that we didn't like so that we could
listen for
wall-to-wall meaning
uh from the as long as a tape would
allow we would cram
three albums worth of songs on like one
of those extend play right once you take
out a few of the duds
but
at a certain point we did i mean
i i eventually started collecting merle
albums so that we could hang them on the
wall and it was a representation and a
continuation of the experience that we
had in high school like i don't even
know if i
understood that's what i was doing when
i was collecting those moral albums off
of ebay and hanging them in every single
studio that we've ever had including our
office right now but yeah it's my
collection but it's definitely it
represents our
friendship and
something that
became a
permanent part of our identity
i mean definitely our brand you know
um but also who we are as people
like we love merle so much that like i
could get i can easily get emotional
right now talking about it when he died
i remember the meeting that we were in
and i remember thinking
am i going to have to walk out of this
meeting
and then like not walking out of the
meeting and then saying okay i can
compartmentalize this
but it's the it's the musical focus of
our friendship in a way that all of our
experience with the wax paper dogs and
i'm so glad that you like applied that
filter to incorporating a number of
albums
into your list from that because it was
so important and it's it's only
overridden in our friendship by i think
our moral experience where it was like
it was just about the enjoyment it
wasn't it wasn't even about what we were
going to create it was about the
experience of being together and we
would talk about
the experiences from the albums
from the songs the fact that he chose to
write about certain songs
the album i picked is
i'm always on a mountain when i fall
i somehow i still have this tape
now i remember that
you your dad had this tape and then i
got a copy of it because
yeah he had that uh it has my favorite
merle song which this was released in
1978
my favorite song is i'm always on a
mount when i fall the title of the album
too incidentally it's it's a song that
he didn't write which makes me feel
weird about it being my favorite but it
is what it is the production on this is
the album you read about the album now
and it didn't do well it was one year
later is when he released
servant 190 proof and everybody that was
like a renaissance for merle and but
i listen to this and the the production
and the subject matters that he talks
about i mean
this has the immigrant on it that's i
mean
that's relevant today
uh all of these songs are so many of
these songs are so good but like on the
b side life of a rodeo cowboy and there
ain't no good chain gang are great
but the best song of this album it's
been a great afternoon yeah i mean the
fact that he's he's he's got a radio hit
out of a song where he's talking about
being hung over and the only way he can
get over his hangover is to have
an enthralling sexual encounter
in the in the early afternoon and the
celebration of that is something that
was hilarious to us
as
conservative high schoolers it was it's
like he snuck things in that we were
like what couldn't show my i couldn't
let anybody know i was listening to
chili peppers or
uh if it was dr dre but he snuck it on
the radio and talking about all this
kind of stuff well and that's that's
interesting because and then that's just
that's essentially just
racism
at that point right the fact that yeah
old white country dude you can talk
about things that are pretty explicit
but it was veiled language it was veiled
but but you know but i mean not very you
know yeah it was the fact that like yeah
i can sit here and listen to this with
my dad but you know if a guy's gonna be
rapping about his sexual exploits that's
uh that's a different that's off limits
that was that was just part of the sort
of the white culture that we were in
could you have predicted that this was
this is my picture i knew that i knew
that would be your album okay okay
because i for me it got down to uh
that
790 improve in big city it was kind of
like that that he was just doing so many
amazing things at that time i think that
was eight and uh so yeah i kind of again
i was like i got to pick one and i went
with uh you know 790 proof just because
i was like i think that i have more
favorite songs on this it made me feel
bad that i didn't put it in number one
but again the re i stand by not putting
it in number one i agree with everything
that you just said but because there's
not
margaret is my all-time favorite artist
but it's just
i never really experienced the albums i
would take him and make him do the
compilations and so it just didn't
it didn't come together oh my feelings
don't hurt um well this is like i know
your station
one of the things that kind of came
clear to me as i was
speaking of racism
uh that that kind of came together for
me as i was looking at this is i was
like
and again i actually it registered with
me
and then i made the decision to not go
back and change it to try to present
myself in a different light because i
was i wanted it to be an honest
assessment of what i've connected with
over my life
all 10 of my albums are from men and 9
out of 10 are from white men
i'm a white man
which might explain some of it um
but to me it was this message of like
hmm okay this is
these are these are the albums that i've
kind of
connected with or have like influenced
me
and been meaningful or been my favorite
musically again there was lots of
different reasons that went into it
and it's you know
you well you might ask yourself like
okay well why isn't lionel richie on the
list lionel's not on the list even
though he would make my top 10 favorite
artists he's not on the list again
because i experienced lionel in
compilation and greatest hits
and it wasn't so much i would expect the
albums when they came out because it
just i wasn't i i found lionel later
found lionel in college
but ultimately
it to me it was just a little bit of a
wake-up call it's just like oh you know
i'm kind of moving into your second half
of life here as a middle-aged white man
thinking about being more intentional
about not just falling into
the music that is obviously
made for me by people like me
and just being more intentional seeking
seeking out
uh thinking about the representation in
my musical taste essentially it was a
little bit of a a wake-up call
for me i mean obviously i've been in a
hip-hop for a long time and
that made my honorable mentions and that
kind of thing but it isn't like
something that i have
been as conscious of as i would like to
be yeah well i think because of the
criteria of these are just like
meaningful moments in in my past
i think it is indicative of like having
a narrower view like yeah i mean i was i
was very narrow in how i approached
music
uh for for a long time i would only
listen to one i was only into one genre
in like middle school and high school
you know like especially those times
right as a kid but i mean for me now i
think i've got a pretty diverse
listening palette so
but but that's this list doesn't
represent that yeah i agree with that
because it's not it's uh
it's it's more about
a timeline of experience for me but
i would love to make uh
um just favorite albums and i think that
i think that that would come to
come to bear in a in a good way on that
but um
before you give you a wreck just because
you already had all this figured out
with your your list i i want to just
quickly run through ones that didn't
make the list that i still recommend as
albums okay fuji's the score oh yeah
uh uh honorable mention is miseducation
for me i didn't put for obvious reasons
i didn't put michael jackson on the list
but
michael jackson's thriller was obviously
one of the most influential albums for
me personally
but yeah he's disqualified himself all
your favorite bands dolls
uh
awaken my love childish gambino
one of my favorite like from the past
like 10 years
under the radar kershaw branches david
bazan
uh
which if from a deconstruction
standpoint i highly recommend it means a
lot to me jackson brown jackson brown
mark cohn mark cohn
illinois
sufjan stevens oh yeah
uh
and then i already talked about never
mind nirvana low in theory tribe called
quest was on my and then blood sugar sex
magic was a was a
those were the ones i had to move out of
the top ten yeah i mean
i don't think my
i don't have any honorable mentions
because that's just i have so many
favorite albums it's just a different
list for me
the overlap is just so little that i'm
not gonna do that and i'm also not going
to make a recommendation because with
this whole album yeah that's what the
whole thing was my recommendation is a
reminder to go to the retin-link spotify
and look at the playlist there that
we've created so you can listen to some
of this music and then you can drill
down
and like
go to the album that that the song that
we picked for the playlist is on if you
want to listen to the whole album if you
know how spotify works
uh that is how it works so you can do
that thanks for listening tell us um
where you crossed over with us and where
you diverge the power of music
your biscuits
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best